the og crypto derivatives platform
and the best place to buy your bitcoin
hey guys and welcome back to the lehigh pen show
this show and this episode is going to be a very
special one a little bit different from what we
usually talk about but very much in line with
the whole concept of freedom and becoming that
sovereign individual so i'm really excited
to kick things off but before we do this podcast
as you know is sponsored by bitmex so a quick
message from bitmex bitmex is the og crypto
derivatives exchange and now has a spot exchange
for you to buy and sell crypto especially in
a bear market you really need a place that you
can trust and bitmex sets the standard in
reliability performance and transparency and
has proven itself through multiple market cycles
so it stood the tesla time which is very important
right now bimx is actually celebrating the start
of bitmex spot with one million dollars in prizes
to give away so to enter all you have to do
is trade the equivalent of 250 u.s dollars in
crypto so you could buy some bitcoin 250 worth of
bitcoin um to enter buy the dip and you could also
um you can also um enter up to 25 times which
basically means you could win up to 500 thousand
dollars in bitcoin so lots of prizes there to win
um and a massive thank you to bimx again because
on this show we do have the conversations
that nobody else is having really topical
conversations that you're not sort of allowed to
have right now um so a huge thank you to bit max
i'm leaving all of that information for you in the
description below if you are watching on youtube
um and before i bring on my guests i do want to
ask you all to subscribe hit the like button so
you can support the channel and you never miss any
of this really valuable content alright guys let's
get this going so joining me on the show today
is the world traveler investor entrepreneur and
founder of nomad capitalist it is andrew henderson
andrew welcome to the show how are you i'm
glad to be with you great to be with you too
i've been um following a lot of your stuff
for a while and i like it a lot um it's very
much in line with um the sorts of ideas that
i that i talk about in terms of being that
sovereign individual you know preparing for
um all that's going on in the world um so let's
just kick this off for those who don't really
know much about you can you just give us a brief
background about who you are and what you do
so i founded a company called nomadcalculus which
was a result of my traveling all around the world
and noticing uh inconsistencies noticing
arbitrage opportunities where investments
would be higher yielding in one country or
the people would be nicer in a different
country and so i was traveling all around the
world i noticed that where i was from the u.s
didn't really like a lot of what was going
on there had been talking since i was a child
with my family about how it was going to become
a less positive place for entrepreneurs for
successful people for investors and noticed
that the culture in their places was more
conducive to entrepreneurship the people were
more welcoming they were more understanding
again interest rates were higher or whatever and
so uh i went i thought back to what my father
told me when i was 12 years old go where you're
treated best you don't have to stay in the same
city the same state the same country and i got a
great permission slip to not have to stay around
and take care of my family they said listen we're
going to take care of ourselves and you should go
where you're treated best and so i
started noticing how that's not one place
what my father talked about in the
mid 1990s of moving to new zealand
or moving to chile is not the way that today you
need to do it you don't just move everything down
to new zealand or to chile you can diversify and
so that's what we talk about we talk about having
passports residence permits you know tax companies
everything in all the different places around
the world so that you can take advantage of
what each country has to offer that's best
so you you know you spoke about go where
you're treated best but there must have
been something which really sparked you to want
to start a more established nomad capitalist
well i had started a number of businesses
in the u.s and had done relatively well
starting that at 19 20 years old you know back
then entrepreneurship it was not a hashtag on
instagram it was something that was kind of weird
and so socially speaking it was difficult and i
noticed when i traveled to europe i had much
better conversations about entrepreneurship
with people my age people seem to be a lot more
interested in it um whether from a friend's
perspective whether just you know from a from a
dating perspective it just seemed to jail more
and then later in asia as well um and also i was
paying at the peak like 43 of my income in taxes
um and that was really inefficient so i basically
said from a social perspective for me i want to
explore the world from a hey what's happening in
asia this is like the future i want to be part of
that um from all of that i started asking myself
well okay how does it work with taxes like if
you can work from anywhere if you can make money
anywhere how does that work and i realized you can
you can dramatically lower if not even eliminate
your tax bill by living somewhere else and so
for me it's like all right i'm going to save a
bunch of money and i'm going to live in a place
or places that's much more conducive to what i
want and i'm going to have an adventure and so
it kind of uh spiraled from there over the
last dozen or so years now with homes in
six different places and multiple
passports and a very global lifestyle
um you know it's it's been one where i've
created a lot of optionality for myself
just out of interest do you find it exhausting
that nomad that digital nomad lifestyle
what when i first started well i guess when
i very first started it was i had a home in
the united states and i traveled more and more
and more to where at one point i was home less
than i was away and i actually brought in like a
roommate because i i bought a house and i didn't
want someone to break into the house because i
was not really there that often um and so you
know that travel where you leave for a month or
two months and you come back and i would you know
leave and come back from europe three days later
go to asia um that wasn't exhausting because you
always have that base then i did the perpetual
nomad where you say i'm going to travel throughout
southeast asia and every month i'm going to be
in a new country i'm going to meet people i'm
going to meet the ceo of a bank i'm going to meet
somebody in uh you know entrepreneurship whatever
um that certainly i think does get old where
you're dragging a suitcase behind you what
i developed was the system of having a base i
first found malaysia as a place to have a base
it's still one of the six bases and so you know
as i'm going to travel for a conference we're
hosting in mexico city uh in september uh i'm
going to pack up all my clothing in one place
go to the other and then you know come back to
another home so it's much less exhausting having
that infrastructure where you have places that
you can call home i think that what people should
understand is my lifestyle doesn't have to be your
lifestyle some people a lot of our clients they
say you know i make three million dollars a year i
want to be in one place i want the time zone to be
good so if they're working with americans they're
going to live either in portugal or in ireland or
they're going to live in panama or or something
like that and so they just live in that one place
it's a tax friendly place and that's what they
do and that saves them on taxes and they still
get to diversify and everything or you can live
my trifecta four months in three different places
or you can be a little bit chaotic about it which
i've done but you always have those homes and so i
think that if you build the infrastructure over
time it's a lot less chaotic so we're gonna get
into um what the best places are you mentioned
portugal which is an interesting one actually um
but before we do what would you say some of the
disadvantages are to only having one passport
well i think what we've seen in recent years is um
your country entirely controls what you can do one
of the big things there's been a few big trends in
the last couple of years one of them is the advent
of a wealth tax and related taxes like unrealized
capital gains tax i'm talking about trends in u.s
canada australia new zealand uk western countries
uh germany as well um wealth tax is one of them
uh retroactive taxes even but also oh let's cancel
your passport what was boris johnson talking about
if we don't like uh the way that you you conducted
yourself overseas will you reserve the right to
cancel your passport the u.s can cancel your
passport for tax debts other countries talked
about that people from australia couldn't come
back to their own country during the pandemic
in canada it's the one country in the world it's
tightening entry restrictions and so you may not
be able to leave your country you may not be
able to come back to your country for overseas
if you were stuck overseas everyone thinks like
the vietnam war the helicopters come and save you
if you're an american uh everyone had to pay for
themselves and you can say that's a good fiscal
strategy but the idea that you're getting a
benefit for being a citizen of a country is
is just not there and so they can do whatever they
want the united states where i'm from taxes people
no matter where they live merely because you
carry that passport and so you can dramatically
reduce those taxes it's a little bit harder than
a few years ago but you can get it down to zero or
probably single digits but you've still got a
phone home to the irs you've still got to tell
them where your bank accounts are and you're
still subject to u.s regulations i have people
who do business in southeast asia for example
and the way that business is done there doesn't
match up with the way the u.s uh requires their
citizens to conduct themselves so whether it's
taxing you whether you live there or not whether
it's restricting your freedom of movement whether
it's forcing you to do anything that takes away
from your freedom um i mean there's so many things
that they can do and you know for me when i first
got the second passport the first second passport
there's a there's a different feeling i think
you feel it and it's like you know what now i
have options and if this country over here
decides to screw me hey i can go over here i
ultimately gave up u.s citizenship for a number
of reasons um i wasn't really paying much in in
taxes legally so the taxes contrary to the media's
narrative wasn't really the issue but i just felt
like they were making it harder and harder and
harder to be an expat i was a citizen which should
be a benefit but in many cases countries and
politicians are saying no no it's an obligation
canada now they want citizens a few politicians
are talking about you should pay taxes for the
privilege of being canadian i thought it was
you had the privilege of having us as part of
the country and it was a service to us who are
part of this tribe no they see it the other way
and so don't you want to have a backup plan or
multiple backup plans in addition to more places
you can live without asking permission you want to
have backup plans for whatever your country can do
because i think we've seen it's going to get worse
yeah do you think that um the need for multiple
passports and dual citizenship is becoming more
necessary as the years go by well and when how
long ago was it like okay all right fine the u.s
uh it's it's a dump but uh hey you're from canada
right um i mean you you donate money to some
people and they freeze your bank accounts um by
the way you know people say oh well singapore
is not perfect andrew banks in singapore well
that's great i don't live in singapore i don't
really care what happens in singapore as long as
my money is safe and the banks stay in the top 15
safest on earth i'm not there protesting whatever
they're doing in singapore and so that's the point
of the diversification right i mean when you're
banking for example in the same country that you
are living and you have a political interest i
mean that's a challenge right so i want to just
live in a place to live i live in malaysia part
of the year and whatever they want to do it's not
my business and they treat me well and i get left
alone and everyone's nice and the tax plan leaves
me alone and so uh it's not my business how they
want to run their country but you know canada was
the place to go australia was a place new zealand
how many wealthy people i was saying five years
ago new zealand there's much better alternatives
at a lower price point that are just better and
now everyone's kind of coming to realize that
and so i think that you know what i've
talked about is legacy brand countries
um countries that have this this it's it's it's
coca-cola right um and why is it cooked like why
don't you drink rc cola why don't you drink
the store brand because coca-cola has been
around it's the legacy brand they advertise
right um montenegro doesn't really advertise
right malaysia doesn't really advertise and
so you don't think about those places but yet
the countries that are legacy brands are
getting away with murder in some cases
you mentioned um how the relationship between the
people and the government um in times of you know
is it isn't it supposed to be a privilege
that i'm part of your country rather than
it's a privilege to hold that canadian passport
yeah um so so in what way is that relationship
changing between the citizens and the state and
um why do you think it's changing uh it was moving
towards a more negative relationship for us well
i think it's largely happening in i mean like look
at the five ice countries for example look at
larger countries i mean i i had um i was a very
controversial guy the former president of georgia
mikhail sakashvili who basically put in the
constitution that you have to have a referendum
to increase taxes they slashed taxes from 21 to
five or six they flattened all the rates they
dramatically lowered all the rates and you cannot
raise those taxes by the way you can live there
and pay zero or one percent as a foreigner but you
can't raise those taxes without everyone getting
together and voting it's not just the legislature
and and and he seems to think that his country's
a little bit too small because it's hard to govern
and make tough choices because you walk around
to belize the capital and you see the people
who you had to lay off and you see their
families but because it was a small country
they could turn around at a dime they
fired the entire police force one day
because it was corrupt and they brought in all
new people you're not going to do that in the u.s
how do you solve the problem in the u.s or even
the uk or even canada number one the culture is
people are so addicted to the fact that they're
living in a legacy brand country that this is the
best how long does it take to breed that out of
people right where they're just going to accept
whatever comes down because this is the best even
people who complain about it on our channel are
like sure but it's still the best thing out there
statistically it's not by any measure right you
have like the 59th worst crime rate the 72nd or
something like that uh corruption i mean like it's
statistically best u.s canada australia number one
in nothing but everyone thinks it is they're going
to keep supporting politicians that keep going
further and further down higher taxes anti-freedom
uh on the other hand right uh they're just such
big countries how are you going to make how is
the u.s going to turn on a dime i mean like okay
i'm going to vote for republicans george w bush
took your tax rate from 39 to 35 percent woohoo
right trump took it to 37. if you make over what
400 grand 450 whatever it is you're paying 37 plus
plus plus california is raising everyone's worth
right and so uh you could just move somewhere else
and pay zero or pay one or pay five there's plenty
italy and greece for the love of pete have tax
incentives where you can make as much money as
you want and pay one flat rate italy and freaking
greece right at least there's a little bit of
acknowledgement and those kind of like we need
to bring in some cash the u.s isn't ever going to
have that they'll just print more the uk they're
not going to change so what would you say some of
the multiple um well what are some of the benefits
of having multiple passports well i think the
biggest thing is optionality right so there's a
number let's talk about how you can get one if you
have a parent grandparent great grandparent you
can get citizenship potentially where they're from
so if you've got an irish grandparent you can get
irish citizenship okay now you can live in the uk
and they've got a tax incentive for foreigners
you can live in ireland the tax incentive may
be difficult if you're not a foreigner but
possible you can live anywhere you want in
the european union and obviously the european
union is not as free as many places but there are
places that are better for certain things bulgaria
for example was ahead of the game in some things
uh even parts of spain that kind of thing so
you get to choose um if you have that passport
do you want to live there do you not um but but
that's through dissent you can make an investment
i have a passport in the caribbean um they don't
bother you it's the exact opposite of the u.s
they don't want your taxes they don't want to know
anything about you okay are you a criminal do you
have a good character we're gonna do a background
check if you're approved here's your citizenship
my point is like they're not going to be tracking
your banking they're a peaceful small country
no one hates the saint lucians no one hates the
antiguans right no one's going to get into a tiff
with the antiguans and say you can't get a visa
to come to our country so i think it allows you
to continue to do business to bank to diversify
your assets have another place to live when times
get tough um have another passport to travel on
open up new places to travel to have a different
you know identity not that you should lie about
which citizenships you have or claim that you're
not an american when you are an official
proceeding whatever but um it just gives you the
option to to pivot uh and if one day your country
does something where they want to take more of
your money let's say elizabeth warren gets her way
or let's say i just i just did a video the other
day about um there's some group that wants to roll
out a simple flat tax wealth tax on oligarchs in
the us eight percent a year imagine they come
after say every year you have to give us eight
percent of your net worth you can say you know
what here's your passport back i'm going over here
and who knows how much more difficult it could
be in the future as the us has tried to force
legislation to to push places like europe to
stop letting these caribbean citizens come
so i mean they don't like competition the big
governments are angry and that's what this whole
global minimum tax that you're reading about is
about how dare you have a tax rate of nine percent
if you're a small country you want to
encourage business to come and hire your people
and do what's right for your citizens but the big
established countries the mafias as it were they
don't want competition they want to snuff that out
they want to make sure you have to keep paying 37
and so having a passport is in the most extreme
of ways the backup plan that you can say i'm out
how many passports can you hold at once i believe
different countries have different rules yeah
so most countries i mean there is a trend towards
dual citizenship we've seen countries like norway
more recently we've seen like liberia and africa
which you know there are people who can claim
african citizenship by descent but more countries
are opening up germany now the government they
want to tax tax tax but the one good thing they're
talking about is allowing germans more freedom in
in dual citizenship so that's the trend
uh if you have the ability to hold dual
citizenship generally speaking let's say you're
american you're british you're australian
it basically means when you're in that country
when you're in the u.s you should be an american
you have to enter in your u.s passport leave on
your u.s passport and so if you get arrested for
example hopefully no one's getting arrested
but if you get arrested in the united states
you can't say hey i'm also a dominican let me
call the dominica embassy and then let me help now
you're an american you're here you're an american
but what they say is we don't really care what you
do outside of the country and so you could hold
i mean one guy was was reputed to have eight
um you know i hold what five and i was going
for a sixth um so there's really no limit in
most cases as long as none of the countries has
a limit so you'll see some countries where they
restrict dual citizenship um you'll see others
like russia there's a reporting requirement and
i saw someone got in trouble recently for not
reporting it fast enough um but if you're if
you're allowed to have dual citizenship
that could be triple quadruple multiple
what's the quickest and easiest way to get
your second passport well it depends i mean
i think citizenship by descent through ancestry
depending like if you've got a parent who is
born in canada for example a lot of people don't
know this if you're born in canada born in mexico
born in most countries in the americas you are a
citizen by birth when i give up u.s citizenship
it doesn't say because your parents are american
and says you obtain citizenship by birth in the
united states and so uh people don't realize
if their parent was canadian or mexican or
argent you know born there they can apply for that
passport and so canada i think is relatively fast
uh but citizenship by descent has definitely
slowed down might take a couple of years
uh if you just want the fastest path you would
look at something like citizenship by investment
so you've got five caribbean countries you've got
montenegro where i've got a home i think it's a
very overpriced program you've got turkey which
recently increased but that's the really the only
program where an investment makes sense you get
to buy real estate not just real estate on a list
as is the case in the caribbean but you get to
buy real estate anywhere in turkey so if you buy
correctly most people don't if you buy correctly
you can sell that in three years and probably
come out about even so for our purposes
i would suggest there are five caribbean
countries where the general option is you make
a donation from a hundred thousand dollars on up
or you go to turkey which has a different kind
of passport obviously it's a big country it's
they have their own beefs of people um but it's
an investment and so which one do you want if
you're if you're in bitcoin you probably want
to keep as much money in bitcoin as possible
you'd rather spend a hundred thousand dollars in
st lucia dominica what have you then invest 400
four and a quarter and wait a couple of years um
so those are probably the six fastest options uh
when you figure out all the paperwork you've
got to collect and apple style and everything
else you're probably looking at six to seven eight
months you said that you have five passports can
you tell us which countries those are i don't talk
about it i don't think people should talk about it
i've talked about some of them i've talked about
st lucia for example the caribbean and i was
very happy to see that uh you know americans are
900 up in terms of applications in st lucia and
maybe one day they'll they'll give
me a flag pin or something but um
i don't talk about i don't think you should um i
mean i think that uh you want to uh you know you
want to be diversified you want to have options
i you know i i specifically so i help my wife
get armenian citizenship through dissent and she
thought it was silly at the time and i think a lot
of people who have good passports think it's silly
to get such a low quality quote-unquote passport
and yet what she found was it was so much easier
to get residence permits around the world because
she can get an armenian police report in
one day she can get anything done in one
day the embassies are actually helpful unlike
where she's from and like where i'm from where
everything takes a lot longer so it's a much
better identity and especially right now where
she's from is from moscow and it's not really the
best way to represent yourself in many places so
um that was a good diversification for uh for
her um you know you can talk about that because
that's your identity um but you know i certainly
wouldn't want someone who is armenian to go and
do the turkish citizenship by investment and by
the way if turkey knew they wouldn't offer it to
you and if armenia knew that you were turkish they
wouldn't let you naturalize probably so i wouldn't
suggest doing something like that um but certainly
you never know when a conflict could break out and
i wouldn't necessarily want to be uh on the
record not that i believe in doing things uh
i mean i believe in being very much on the up and
up but um i certainly wouldn't want to put things
out there needlessly yeah no i understand that
makes a lot of sense no yeah i i agree with you
i um you said um low quality passports so i want
to get more information on that what countries
would you regard as low quality and then which
countries would you say are good passports to hold
i think what i'm using is the is the kind of the
speech that you hear people saying like they look
at the travel privileges of an armenian and it's
not it's not a lot uh you can come to asia um you
can travel within kind of central asia you can
go to georgia whatever but like you're not going
to europe without a visa there's a lot of places
you can't go and so what i've categorized it is
there's three tiers of citizenship there's tra
which is american british australian where you
can pretty much go everywhere the united states
and australia probably being two of the hardest
you know okay a minus it's like romania where
you're pretty much going everywhere as an eu
citizen but you need a visa for the us then you've
got tier b which is most of what i have which is
um you can go to europe right you know
you can go to the schengen area in europe
uh b plus would be could also go to the uk and
ireland which all the caribbean passports have
right um and then t or c would be you can go to
neither the u.s or europe and that would be where
armenia falls that would be technically where
turkey falls turkey's pretty strong this is a
big country and there's lots of countries around
the world would love to have there was 80 million
people coming so turkey or russia are pretty
strong outside of the west because all the other
countries want them armenia obviously or a country
like that doesn't really have a lot of negotiating
power to open up all those countries to travel to
and so they're not particularly wealthy they're
not particularly big and so um you know the
passport isn't as good for travel but here's
the thing if you're british if you're american
why wouldn't you claim that especially if you
have armenian descent it makes sense and then you
can use it to go to the countries that they can
go to you can get a residence permit using that
passport potentially more easily than you could
as an american or british person in some cases
it's just it's nice diversification and you have
one big country one small country so i think it
depends on the mix like i got st lucia if you came
to me and said i want a passport in the caribbean
that would probably be my last suggestion
but for me it meshed well with the other passports
i had i already had the visa free travel gaps that
st lucia has covered somewhere else and i thought
that okay for me i want something that's a bit
newer doesn't really have much of a reputation
you know like doesn't have a bad reputation hasn't
been exposed in some story and i thought you know
that's why st lucia but if i were recommending it
to someone else that would probably be last on
my list if you were getting one passport so you
have to take things you know collectively right
if if you're egyptian with of armenian descent
okay take it but that's not really solving
your problems as much as if you're british
and you can add armenian now you can go to
russia you can go to china you can go to iran
you've got big country small countries so
that's what i mean it's diversification
it depends what you have i understand um and so in
terms of you did talk about this earlier but the
passport itself whose property is that so i know
some people without naming names or making things
too obvious um who during the lockdowns were taken
from the airport and had to go into quarantine
camps and their passports were taken um so they
literally had to go um so who owns your passport
whose property is it well i think when you when
you're in the international airport and you're
going through the border i mean they can stop you
um i won't name any names or countries either but
there's certain places in the americas where um i
mean they they'll put you in a i mean both the u.s
but also some of the latin countries where they're
just like oh sit over here for a while they take
your passport and they're supposed to let you
call the embassy and they don't have to so it's
important to go to places where you are welcomed
and where they're just cool but in terms of who
owns your passport itself yeah the government owns
your passport um they don't have to issue you one
again in the united states and i encourage
everyone to comply with the tax laws but i
got into a scuffle with california many many many
years ago when i was much less successful over a
thousand bucks uh imagine if you were 50 times as
successful and it was 50 000 well now you can be
on the irs radar and they can cancel your passport
or refuse to issue one by communicating with the
state department and so other countries are doing
that in different ways for different reasons
and so they absolutely own it they don't have to
let you travel now uh you are supposed to leave
the us on a u.s passport um you know there's no
exit controls in the u.s so some people kind of
have a hard time understanding how that works but
let's say you were a resident of mexico you know
could you go to mexico and walk over and then have
another passport to travel obviously i encourage
people to play by the rules um but you know if you
can't get a passport listen pay your taxes uh and
if you don't want to pay them then go where you're
treated best but uh you know i think the fact that
they can they can stop you from traveling yeah i
think that just blows my mind um and in terms of
you know what you do you help people um obviously
obtain different passports and things like
that i'm interested to know has your um your
content online your clientele just everything
increased during the last two years after
people saw what has happened i i forget the
percentages but it's been very very substantial
yeah that's crazy um so this year we're kind of
taking the time we're still up but it's not
up like 400 percent anymore partially because
uh from a business point of view we want to
we want to kind of reposition and make sure
that we're we have the right people in place to
to to drive that because it's just it's been uh
it's been extremely overwhelming for the last
two years it's been non-stop uh and i'm glad
that there's a little bit of peace right now but
no it's been crazy and what's been interesting to
me is i've been saying this stuff for a decade and
for the first time you see people from countries
like australia who are like why do i need a
passport oh you mean your country that violated
international law and would let you into the
country or out of the country i mean like the u.n
probably not our favorite organization what is it
they said decades ago everyone should be able to
enter their country and leave their country that's
like citizenship 101 like you can come and you can
go um and they violated that and so everyone who
was like oh you're living now you live in malaysia
yeah okay well i left malay nobody stopped me
from leaving malaysia uh now i mean there were a
few countries where if you were a citizen of the
country um they restricted citizens well that's
the kind of country you wouldn't be a citizen
of you'd be a resident that's the country to be
where citizenship would be difficult so we're
finally seeing all these western countries not
just for tax reasons but now for personal freedom
reasons seeing that the bloom is off the roads and
their place is just it's just an expensive version
of everything else it's like uh you know i need
some shoes i'm going to prada listen if you like
prada shoes buy them and pay 20 times the price
but you are paying 20 times the price uh for not
that much better shoes i happen to like the shoes
so i buy them but like i get it like you could
buy leather shoes somewhere else and so people
are realizing i'm paying all this money right
what was it in germany recently um landlords
are turning off air conditioning because this
government you pay half your money and taxes to
couldn't figure out that the west has been at
odds with the country that provides a lot of
their energy for how long now and they never had
a backup plan so that in the middle of the summer
landlords are conserving by turning off people's
electricity and you've been paying them all these
years to figure it out for you don't hey just
relax and we'll take care of it you paid the bill
and they don't deliver the service yeah it's
absolutely incredible and i think it was trump
actually who predicted that that
was going to happen and everybody uh
sort of laughed at him um for saying that
um but the last few years have been so
enlightening and fascinating for a lot of people
i know people often say they were red pilled over
the last two years you know really like realizing
and the extent to which the government will go
um so which countries would you say have but have
um become more free has anything sort of changed
your mind and which countries are more favorable
than others well there's two areas that we focus
on so our area is on holistic planning so it's
finances freedom and lifestyle and i think that
especially coming from a u.s background you have
to match it up it's not just a matter of leaving
the u.s and hoping it all works you've got to
figure out your residence your citizenship your
tax plan your personal your corporate everything
at once um so there's the tax part and i like
the fact that countries like malaysia and uruguay
came out and said we're not going to raise taxes
um i like the fact that you're seeing again
some of these countries in europe that are
that are doubling down on their tax incentives
including the italy's the greece the islands
uh etc um for personal freedom we've seen latin
america obviously mexico has been a standout
they were wide open through all of it now they
are becoming um i mean it's not just you you can't
live in mexico as a tourist anymore good thing is
residence is pretty affordable to get you don't
need to invest you need to have money but the days
of the 180 day tourist visa no questions ask leave
come back a day later that's over by all means
in mexico but mexico is free um i mean panama was
difficult at first i think i was in colombia for a
good chunk of 2021 and i would say that was pretty
good the people are a bit more conservative but
that was pretty good from a government standpoint
and what i would encourage people to think also is
when you see some of the laws um you know like i'm
going to give example i was in istanbul the end
of 2020 and when i got there they said oh we're
having a weekend lockdown we poke our heads out on
saturday everyone's walking around they're selling
hot dogs and hamburgers on the streets uh kids are
playing in the squares and the police are watching
if that's a lockdown right i mean tell me
that's the same lockdown as what they had in
new zealand or australia or canada it's not the
same and so people say oh walk down it's no better
there believe me all right it's a lot better and
so let america was one place even though they had
some things nobody enforced it and then eastern
europe was pretty open i was in serbia for the
fourth quarter of 2020 um and they closed some
restaurants but i think better uh generally that
was pretty good and so those have been the two
parts of the world from a personal standpoint that
have been good if you think that the pandemic
is over that asia is not ready for you um but
certainly i think for personal freedom in general
um asia leaves you alone for the most part
um eastern europe let america be good and then
for low taxes um you know you're seeing more
small countries double down on tax incentives
yeah that's really interesting um what about um
you mentioned the prada shoes which i thought was
really funny um and do you think we'll get to a
point where these um more these countries like
the us canada and the uk will have to start to
offer better incentives because people are leaving
because we're moving into this digital era whereby
you know i don't need to be based in the uk
i don't need to be based in the us in order
to make good money i can be based anywhere
um so do you think i don't know even in like
10 15 years they might change their tune
slightly in order to be more competitive
it'll be interesting to see um again i'm a
big believer in smaller countries are best i
think the biggest legacy brands like the us the
coca-colas the products whatever it is yeah um
sure change happens in the margins but i think
that i mean most people are still going to want
to go to the us and by the way the argument from
a lot of americans is look at everyone coming here
yes by the way i feel very badly and i think the
u.s is largely to blame yes all the uh salvador
and economic migrants who are coming to the
country because they're pla because they're not
safe where they live and because they don't have
any money if that's not really a barometer like we
want billionaires coming we want people building
factories coming and i'm not saying we don't want
them coming also but you know the effect that
they're coming doesn't mean that you shouldn't
leave if you're making a million dollars a year
or if you've got a 10 million dollar portfolio
your needs are a little bit different my fear is
that yes you will see marginal changes in places
like the u.s um i think you're going to see a big
change in the u.s in the next 15 years because
all these people are moving to florida
and texas in addition to immigration
and it's going to become impossible for anybody
who wants to keep taxes low to win um but
you know to me it's about culture and you know as
they say about alcoholism uh you gotta hit rock
bottom sometimes right if you have a family member
or a friend who's an alcoholic and they lost their
job and they want to sleep on your couch at a
certain point you got to let them sleep on the
street because maybe it's the only thing that's
going to empower them to fix their situation
and i kind of think that you're going to have to
see that and i'm not one of these doom and gloom
people who thinks that the dollar and the u.s
are tanking to oblivion tomorrow i think that
they've got a lot of force and they're going to
push the agenda just as you're seeing with this
global minimum tax they want to stop competition
they want to make it difficult they want to make
it harder to get a second passport they want
to make other countries raise their tax rates
that's not the u.s deal i mean look at andorra
for example spain and france bullied them for
years and they started taxing people so i
i think that it's going to take a long time
whether it's 10 15 years or 100 years i don't know
um but you know i'd rather be prepared early um
i i i think the biggest countries are going
to fight i see that it's going to be really
interesting and we have touched on tax havens
but i would like to get a bit more detail on that
which would you say the best tax havens right now
um and how easy is it to move there well best is
always relatively because you've got all kinds
of different people so i think one country that
um doesn't get enough attention i think the
people there are fantastic and if you only
speak english it's a great soft landing um is
ireland and you can get irish citizenship by
descent you can get malta citizenship in
about 18 months for a million dollars or less
you can if you're a british citizen you can just
move there or you can get a residence permit and
they've got a great tax incentive for foreigners
it's not talked about enough where basically you
pay for your cost of living and then any other
money you have um on top of that is you could just
stay overseas however it's not really friendly for
cryptocurrency bitcoin what have you uh same there
it's believed and it's not never been really
formalized that they follow kind of the uk
similar law um where it's not as crypto
friendly so if you're an entrepreneur
and you only speak english and like i
was just in ireland a little while ago
i had the most soulful conversations there just
with everyday people that i wouldn't have in asia
for example where it's just more basic they speak
english but it's more basic and so if you want
that that's great but if you're into bitcoin it's
not going to be as great portugal uh is you know
keeps is kept flirting with uh you know we don't
want the bitcoin wealth um so a country like italy
could be good i mean dubai is always good the
cayman alliance are good any of this a couple of
the citizenship by investment countries are good
um antigua saint kitts even if you're a citizen
of another eastern caribbean country you could
live in those countries um you know southeast
asian countries like malaysia and thailand can be
good with a few restrictions and a few caveats so
i mean there's plenty of places to go um
some countries are more bitcoin friendly
others you know cut that out of their tax
exemption like the island um so i mean there's
there's so many places that are coming up um and
it depends on what you want to pay i mean you can
go to uruguay for 10 years you can basically pay
nothing you could also live the trifecta lifestyle
which for me was i want to spend a little bit of
time in a few different places uh i'm loving uh
you know i'm loving each place that i go but after
a while i get bored and so if you live in colombia
for example have a home in columbia you can get
permanent residents by buying a property you can
work towards citizenship without really having
to be there if you speak spanish um and their
their taxation is a day's test if it's if you're
under 183 in a year that's it you can't do that in
most countries in europe because they're going
to start saying ah but you got a car yeah yeah
it's close enough um colombia if you live there
for four months a year it's hardly a tax haven
but it can be a tax haven for you so
there's so many different ways you can do it
and just finally i'd love to get your take on
bitcoin um and crypto but specifically bitcoin
just because um i do regard it as this uh form
of money which facilitates the lifestyle which
you're obviously promoting um so what's your take
do you like bitcoin i do we hold you know bitcoin
i'm a hodler you know i'm not i'm not someone
who's all in on anything it's my personality i'm
a very security minded person and i think that um
you know having varying assets uh is important um
especially because you know holding assets
in some countries entitles you to residence
permits citizenships etc and i think that more
people in in bitcoin should look at that as um
you know oh we we publish on on twitter for
example oh today's price of you know st lucious
citizenship is you know five bitcoin and it's
always like it'll be too soon right and maybe
your country will tax you to oblivion or institute
a wealth tax or you know find some new way to
screw you so before it gets there so you know
better better years too early than a day too late
take some percentage and buy an insurance policy
if you you know buy a half million dollar car
you're not going to spend 300 000 to insure it but
you would spend three thousand dollars to insure
it or even ten thousand dollars to insure it to
make sure you don't get sued when you hit somebody
so i think figure out what you can spend on
insurance and do that and i think that at times
you know that's been my frustration but we've
worked with a lot of people in bitcoin i'm i'm
i hold a position i i believe in it uh but i i
certainly think that um you know diversification
and everything is important understood um but
yeah i think um especially when it comes to
you know that trifecta lifestyle you're talking
about it's for me personally um it's a great way
to keep moving um you know you can't exactly bring
your gold with you um as you travel around the
world and yeah for example colombia i mean like
you can't make every country work for everything
so people talk about mexico we've talked about
colombia oh should i get a bank account in mexico
no you shouldn't i'm not saying there aren't some
strong banks there um but i'm saying that there
is you don't have any bank secrecy not from the
government but from like people like criminals
even um and so you don't want to do that so
bank somewhere else and so yeah if you want
to bring money into colombia it's gonna be a
lot easier to use bitcoin than like having to
carry your cash or your gold because i can tell
you some of those countries in latin america
i mean it's still like are you pablo escobar like
100 000 uh which is why if i had to choose one one
part of the world to skip i love mexico city i
love bogota but i would skip latin america because
i think there's just a lot of bureaucracy in that
part of the world but uh people are fighters there
and i think that you know as a result you can have
some decent level of freedom so yeah i think in
that regard bitcoin works very well yeah this
is also fascinating where can people follow you
um and uh keep up to date with all
the information and value you provide
so um we've got free resources nomadcapitalist.com
uh we have over 1200 blog articles we've written
over the years and and keep up to date youtube
nomad capitalist we've got over a thousand eight
hundred videos we put a new one every day um you
can get our book on amazon nomad capitalist we
recently updated it and so that's like 10 11
bucks and you get kind of a nice succinct idea
of stories what you can do what you can't do just
to kind of wet your uh your beak as it were and uh
you can also go to nomadcapless.com we work with
people we not only have no med capitalist live if
you just want to kind of come and absorb all this
in a in a higher level setting and meet people and
learn from the playbook that's coming up this
year uh and then we also work with uh several
hundred uh clients every year who are um you know
high level investors and entrepreneurs who just
want someone to put all the pieces together
who has the experience in all these different
countries who has the network of lawyers and
accountants in every country and makes sure that
what you do in portugal doesn't screw up what
you're trying to accomplish in the u.s because
i see that far too often so from 3 to 10 bucks
to five grand uh multi-five fakers so basically
whatever you need there's a product a service for
you that fits within your within your um bracket
andrew i wanna thank you so much it's been such a
pleasure having you on um and it's so um important
to have these conversations i feel like i need
to go get another passport now after this so i'm
gonna go deal with that and but thank you so much
for coming on andrew my pleasure thank you so much
and guys thank you so much for watching please
don't forget to hit the subscribe button and the
like button so you never miss a video and we will
see you all next week bye bye the leia hile pancho